hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es einen
objekt orte von mir und zwar so eine
richtig schöne leichte mit
zitronengeschmack das beste ist dass die
total einfach ist und die zubereitung
gar nicht lange gedauert wir haben
nämlich einen größe boden und dann ein
richtig leckere zitronencreme jetzt
zeige ich euch zuallererst die zwei
zutaten für den brösel boden
zum einen sind das butterkeks sich könnt
ihr auch eure lieblings kekse verwenden
zum beispiel schmecken auch vollkommen
butterkekse sehr gut und geschmolzene
butter zuallererst werden die
butterkekse fein gemahlen entweder im
mixer falls ihr kein da habt könnt ihr
sie auch in einen gefrierbeutel geben
und dann mit dem nudelholz so lange
drauf hauen bis sie schön fein sind und
das wird er zusammen mit der butter
vermischen
[Musik]
als nächstes könnt ihr euch schon mal
euren wagram und eine tortenplatte
zurechtlegen werk einen bug haben da hat
der kann auch ganz einfach eine
springform nehmen und da geben wir jetzt
unseren brüssel boden rein und drücken
schon fest an
[Musik]
so mit einem glas kann man das ganze am
allerbesten andrücken und die menge ist
übrigens ausgerechnet für 24 bis 26 cm
durchmesser das heißt ihr könnt ihr
einfach nehmen was ihr möchtet und dem
boden gebe ich jetzt bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank so
dem boden hätten wir erledigt und als
nächstes zeige ich euch die einfache und
leckere zubereitung unserer joghurt
sahne creme
wir benötigen naturjoghurt ich habe den
35 prozentigen genommen außerdem kalte
schlagsahne magazine orangensaft zucker
und zitronen desweiteren vanille extrakt
oder vanille zucker und sahne steif
zuallererst kümmern wir uns um die sahne
die wir zusammen mit dem sahnesteif
aufgeschlagen entweder mit der
küchenmaschine oder mit eurem
handrührgerät
[Musik]
die steif geschlagene sahne muss bis zur
weiterverarbeitung kühl gehalten wenn
ich gibt es jetzt in den kühlschrank und
dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder mit der
joghurt creme und jetzt machen wir
weiter mit den anderen zutaten mich
gerade gezeigt habe und damit das ganze
schön festwirt benutzen wie ragati das
ist eine super alternative zur gelatine
denn ich mag das nicht gerne benutzen
viele von euch benutzen wir in china
auch nicht und das ist eben vegan und
wir müssen jetzt die ak tine zusammen
mit einer flüssigkeit unserer wahl zwei
minuten lang auf kochen das machen wir
jetzt auch als erstes und damit wir so
ein bisschen geschmack reinkriegen habe
ich hier orangensaft gewählt sobald eure
flüssigkeit dann aufkocht müsst ihr ganz
genau zwei minuten lang das ganze küchen
lassen dabei ständig umringt damit auch
am topfboden nichts an klebt
[Musik]
sobald zwei minuten um sind geben wir
alle anderen zutaten mit hinein da
brauchen wir kein temperaturausgleich
bis auf die sache die im kühlschrank ist
die kommt später erst zum einsatz
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt alle zutaten im topf bei
den zitronen mache ich so wenn sie so
groß sind dann reicht meistens eine wenn
sie so klein sind nämlich gerne zwei und
falls ihr bio zitronen da habt dann gibt
auf jeden fall noch den abrieb der
schale reihen
[Musik]
bevor wir jetzt die sahne unterheben
müssen wir das etwas abkühlen lassen 10
15 minuten reichen vollkommen ich rühre
dabei immer mal wieder um und
anschließend nämlich design des frisch
aus dem kühlschrank und hebt sie mit dem
talk show aber gut unter
[Musik]
als nächstes nehmen wir uns unseren
tortenboden aus dem kühlschrank und
geben die creme darüber
[Musik]
jetzt noch einigermaßen glatt streichen
und dann kommt das ganze nimmt
kühlschrank für mindestens 4 stunden
oder über nacht dadurch dass es jetzt
acht uhr abends haben sehen wir uns dann
morgen wieder so wir haben sie jetzt den
nächsten tag meine torte durfte eine
nach seinem kühlschrank auskühlen und es
ist richtig schön fest geworden und als
nächstes kümmern wir uns um den guss und
ich finde am allerbesten passt dazu
einen orangen groß und dafür zeige ich
euch jetzt in zwei zutaten und zwar
benötigen wir zum einen orangensaft und
erneut etwas ärgert ihn
jetzt geht es wieder weiter auf unserem
herd hier wird orangensaft zusammen mit
der agatha um gerätes küchen frei ist
und dann das ganze zwei minuten lang
köcheln lassen
[Musik]
nachdem unser ghost 2 minuten köcheln
durfte habe ich ihnen etwa 10-15 minuten
die ein bisschen ausdampfen lassen damit
ich ihn eben nicht so heißt jetzt hier
auf die torte gebe die dort habe ich
jetzt ganz frisch aus dem kühlschrank
genommen und gibt jetzt den fuß drauf
der ist jetzt sehr flüssig aber macht
euch keine sorgen ab circa 35 grad und
kälter wird er richtig schön fest
[Musik]
der kurs muss jetzt schon fest werden
ich gebe es dafür für eine halbe stunde
in den kühlschrank aber eine
zwischenzeit machen wir schon mal die
deko fertig für die deko habe ich mir
jetzt schon meine sahne mit etwas sahne
steif und vanille extrakt steif
geschlagen und in einen spritzbeutel
gegeben und als nächstes nehme ich mir
eine zitrone und 4
[Musik]
jetzt ist der bus schön fest geworden
man die sahne habe ich hier bereit
gelegt außerdem habe ich hier meine
zitronenscheiben und ich finde sowas
gelben passt doch immer was grün ist es
sieht auch noch total frisch aus der pc
minzblätter ihr könnt auch gerne zum
beispiel pistazien nehmen auch
superschön oder den abrieb von einer
limette einfach den schein abtriebs
schön grün passt auch wunderbar
[Musik]
ihr lieben fertig ist unsere zitronen
torten opec und richtig raffiniert und
lecker ich mag vor allem dass es aus
größtenteils aus joghurt besteht und
deshalb so leicht schmeckt und ich finde
dass ich persönlich können locker zwei
bis drei stücke davon essen weil er
ebenso leicht schmeckt der keks boden
ist genau richtig und die orangen
schicht obendrüber perfekte abschluss
noch mal probieren so lecker lecker
lecker richtig lecker der kuchen der
markus übrigens kalt das heißt er wird
ihn erst also nimmt ihn aus dem
kühlschrank und dann sehen wir ihn
sofort so macht ihr das am besten und
ich genieße das stück jetzt noch im
genauen mengenangaben unten in der
infobox schreibt mir gerne euer feedback
wenn ihr das stück mal ausprobiert habe
und falls ihr genauso begeistert seit
wie ich dann freue ich mich auch über
fotos mit dem hashtag ig sketchen auf
instagram bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]